so let's imagine that each of these
little circles here
represent a member of a population of
bugs and we have two different
populations
of bugs you could view this as
population 1 on the left side of this
orange line
and population two on the right side of
this orange line
and these bugs we're going to think
about just one trait their color
because it's easy to visualize and let's
say that their color
generally helps them camouflage from
predators
so this kind of cloudy white and black
and green
layer that's maybe the environment that
they're in where you might find them
maybe it's the surface of a moss-covered
tree or something like that
and these are two separate populations
of maybe a related species or maybe the
same species but they're two
different populations that are not
intermixing
now the first question is which of these
populations has
more genetic diversity well on the left
here we see that they're all
the same color it looks like a pretty
useful color it seems to hide them
pretty well
camouflage them pretty well on the right
here it's clear that there's more
different types of color some of them
are roughly the same color as what we
see on the left hand side but some of
them are good bit darker and some of
them are a good bit lighter
so the one on the right the population
on the right has more
diversity now one could argue that some
of these very bright circles or some of
these darker circles
might be more susceptible to predators
and that actually
might be the case but what we're going
to think about in this video is not
how many members of the population may
be more or less susceptible to predators
what we're going to think about is does
the diversity
help us when there might be some type of
changes to the environment does it make
the population as a whole
more resilient i'm not talking about any
individual member of the population
and to imagine that let's imagine that
there's some type of environmental
change maybe there's pollution in the
area
that makes the surfaces that these
little bugs have to live on
a good bit darker so maybe the surfaces
look like this
so now what's likely to happen well in
this reality
all of the bugs on our left hand side
are now more
visible to predators and so you can
imagine the predators might be able to
pick off a lot more of them
or in an extreme case maybe it will
finish them off altogether
while on the right some of the members
of the population are easier to pick off
like that one and that one and that one
and that one
while some other members of the
population are even more camouflaged
than they were before
like that one and that one and that one
and so the population because of its
diversity
yes a lot of them might die off they
might be picked off by predators but it
looks like there's a subset of the right
population
that is going to be more likely to
survive and then they can continue to
reproduce and so you won't have the
entire population
dying off and you could imagine it the
other way around
let's say instead of the environment
getting somehow
darker imagine if the environment got
somehow
lighter something like that well you see
a similar phenomenon
all the ones on the left are now very
similarly visible
and maybe the predators could pick them
off
while on the right some of them have
become a lot more visible in this case
the darker ones are now super visible
the predators might be able to
pick them off and even some of the
medium colored but there's a good number
of them
that now blend in quite well like that
one and that one
and i can't even see them that well
they're blending in so well
and so once again there's certain member
of the populations that because of this
more diversity they are more likely to
be able to survive
some type of environmental perturbation
and so since they are more likely to
survive the entire population's
less likely to be killed off so the
population as a whole is more resilient
not saying that every member of the
population is more resilient but the
population
as a whole so the general takeaway here
is that more diversity leads to
more environmental
resilience or resilience to changes
in the environment once again we're not
talking about every individual member of
the population being more resilient
we're talking about the population as a
whole
being able to survive in some way and
then keep carrying on